wilden recently asked what if i want to  access my private google cloud storage  from cloud run  good question it depends on what you  need  one your cloud run service may need to  access files that belong to it  two your service may need to access one  particular google doc like a google  sheet  or three your service may need to access  the current user's google docs in this  video let's talk about the first one the  other two will get separate videos  if you only need to read files and they  don't change very often you can simply  include them in the container your code  can then read them using the native file  reading api  if you need to both read and write files  or if the files change frequently you  can create a bucket in cloud storage and  use the storage client library to access  that bucket  if you're not using the default service  account for cloudron just remember to  give the service account access to the  bucket  stay tuned for how to access google docs  from cloudron